[Music]
no
or no
no I no
[Music]
no
[Applause]
[Music]
no
[Music] a
lot
[Music]
no
I address a cordial and respectful greeting
to the president  of the European Commission
perhaps founds it and with you I greet the
most reverend Excellencies
illustrious close to the kind
Pro-Rector the magnificent rectors and their
delegates the civil and military authorities the
teaching colleagues the technical administrative staff
the male and female students present
in this great hall and  all those who
attend the ceremony remotely
before giving the inaugural speech
I am pleased to invite you to listen
together to the message he wanted to
address to us thinking speak
dear brothers and sisters
for a report of the academic year
of the catholic university of the sacred
heart
I would like to make  my
warmest greetings to the entire university community
represented by the magnificent rector
professors franco rings from as
ecclesiastical assistant general His Excellency
Monsignor claudio
giuliodori and the Director General Paolo it is not known
I also address my greetings to His
Excellency Monsignor Mario Delpini
Archbishop of Milan and President
of the Toniolo Institute and to the President
of the European Commission Mrs Ursula
von der Leyen
what are you  living is a special day
because it celebrates an important anniversary
one hundred years ago father agostino gemini
and his collaborators gave birth to
that great cultural institution
that your university wishes i
would like to gather my thoughts
around three words fire hope
service that words that
i believe
can represent a  then the mystical rose
the first is an image the fire that is the
torch that was transmitted in your university
becomes the only
generation of anniversaries are
suitable moments to remember the past and
looking at the 100 years of life
of the catholic university of the sacred
heart recognizes itself  and an
important educational tradition
brought to life thanks to the dedication of
hundreds of men and women is
witnessed by thousands of
graduates education is one of the most
effective ways to humanize the world of
history and I believe that your university
enshrines this teaching within its mandate
it is possible thanks to the
renewed valorisation through the
generations of the cultural and
spiritual heritage that constitutes its
identity a clear unchanged identity which however does not
reject rather respects welcomes the
different sensitivities in the
awareness that it is from a frank and
respectful confrontation with the other that
the human condition is brought to flowering
as the ancients had already understood well.
educating is not filling the lows but
lighting fires
the catholic university guards this
fire and therefore transmits it a little because it
is the only way to do it and by contact
that is through testimony
personal and community
even before transmitting  what
we know we light the fire by sharing
what we are
this contact takes place thanks
to the meeting to the fact of
sitting on one another's bench and doing something
together and this is the original meaning
of what we call universita
l'universitas when they started  to
arise these realities in the Middle Ages and if they
were born to make the
converge towards
a single place of different schools so many
converge towards one towards one a place
once a spirit
in your case an enlightened history
of faith that restores unity to the universe
of knowledge and  the unity of the
people who contribute to its
growth
the independent professors the students
in this deepest sense of the
word traditions which, as mahler said,
is not the custody of the ashes of the
past but the safeguarding of the future
the second word and hope
today this idea of  education and is given
by an individualistic culture that leaps
liotino position to us
promote indifference  the culture
of indifference is ugly and diminishes
the value of solidarity and sets in
motion the culture of waste.
integral
result of the experiences of the
sensitivity of death this is in
particular the mission of the teachers who
are the creative guardians of the tradition
which has a treasure
because they are according to the image of gustav
mahler as I said it is not to guard the
dinners but
cost of fire that is to bring  forward
the image of the tree no the roots
give life
to the tree and as the poet said
everything that the tree has flowers toe
comes to it from what is its golden
this harmony between says
growth education above all relationship between
dinners between teacher and student and then also
of the students among themselves a community of
people open reality to the other
transcendent to others open  with a
series of discovering proposing questions and
looking for answers together answers
today
not only rates asking questions
part of seeking answers
a community open to the world without
fear fear is ugly and
this is hope betting on the future by
overcoming the natural thorn that arises
from the many fears that risk making us
immovable, they will fix us and close us in
an eternal illusory present.
precisely starting from university classrooms it
builds an
inclusive citizenship as
opposed to the culture of waste in
this perspective I have promoted a
global educational pact to sensitize
everyone to listen to the great questions
of meaning of our time starting from
those that the new generations
in the face of injustices  social and
revelation of  rights to forced migrations
the university cannot remain
deaf to these denunciations I am happy
that you have accepted this invitation to a
renewed season of educational commitment
your international cooperation projects
aimed at different populations of the
planet the many economic aids that each
year you disburse to  students in need
your attention to the last
through the sick are
evidence of a correct commitment I
encourage you to continue on this
path
the world
today above all is totally
interdependent
this condition requires an
unprecedented effort because this
epochal change has made obsolete the
interpretative frameworks of the past which  they are
more useful for understanding the present
it is a question of designing new models of
thought
to define solutions to the urgencies that
we are called to face from
environmental to economic ones from
social to demographic ones we
cannot go on with the categories  history
of the lights of
enlightenment it takes a thought it takes a
new
creative thought the catholic university of the
sacred heart can represent a
privileged place for the advanced development of
such cultural elaborations and here
we return to the teacher-
student relationship which is important that a
dynamic relationship in  tension between
present and future
together you are called to think,
plan and act having common are
of tomorrow's common house starting
from today's concrete reality
I you students address me now in a
particular way
in these confused times I have even
more complexes than the pandemic more I repeat
don't let hope be stolen don't
let hope be found and don't
let yourself be infected by the virus
of individualism
the ugly this hurts
the university the right place to
develop antibodies against this
virus the university open your mind to
reality and diversity
you can put them  bring your talents into play
and make them available  ion of
all
as students of the Catholic University
of the Sacred Heart
belonging to a community of studies with
solid roots from which you can
draw for your training and to
renew every day the enthusiasm to
go forward and assume your
responsibility in society but not
become
traditionalists of the neighbor for the must
have friends to grow to go
ahead to stake my life and this is
the horizon that I propose to you in this
centenary
of so we come to the third and last
word service
in reality this word could be
the first because it is always a  new
institution begins with founders who
put their lives at the service of
others
and over the 600 years the
Catholic university of the sacred heart has demonstrated
on several occasions that it is faithfully at the
service of the church and society
as evidenced by the commitment of its teachers
in the daily activity of receiving it, it is
for many of them also in roles of
responsibility  within the
Italian international institutions, the
work of the staff
who offer dedication intelligence in order
to make the functioning of the university possible,
I address a thought of gratitude
to each of you who are part
of this great team
, here too the logic is  that
of the universitas all together all
towards
all together
each one
in his specific role but all together
converging towards a shared horizon
without the daily work of each of
you this common project would be
poorer but you also see them as if they
were missing in an orchestra  the timbre
and tonality of some instruments
apparently less important
dear brothers and sisters
that I am addressing all of
you again, allow me the example of a large
orchestra where the
whole is essential, each one gives the best in harmony
with the others
the spirit of  service always remains
the hallmark
of your entire
unive community  rsitaria that only in this way is faithful to the
gospel that spies on them
lord jesus christ despite being the locus
of divine wisdom has chosen the
foolishness of serving to the point
of total self-emptying the wisdom of the cross
thus bore witness to the truth
of god's love that he  in rai he
taught us that it served to reign
serve to reign
may anyone who studies and works in
your university
breathe this spirit
to take this style to live it
in the complex reality of the contemporary world
go ahead
look at the horizon with courage in
your educational mission
two words that  a lot of courage and patience will help us
in enduring contradictions the things
that are wrong but patience the leap
of courage go together they go together
you interpret this courage this
patience as a passionate service to
all of society
also to the church but all of society
sir bless
the  madonna protect you
and please don't forget to
pray for me thank you
[Applause]
on December 7,
our story began
today we cross a threshold with the beginning
of this academic year
the second century of life of
this university begins
the year that closed completed a
cycle and was  a time of
commemoration of homage to those who
are indebted to our present I
sincerely thank the many who have done their
utmost to organize the numerous
initiatives which have enriched this
anniversary and which have made us
feel united as a community even in
moments of forced separation
a  a special thought goes to those who first
showed us affection and closeness
to the holy father francis to whom
I address a warm and respectful
thanks for the profound
reflections that he wanted to give us in
his video message
a thread that has crossed the past months
and today is knotted in a bond  of strong
significance
the hundredth academic year was
opened by an unusual ceremony in
images, faces and voices from
all the campuses of the university converged in this then deserted assembly hall and
above all the president of the republic was with us from the quirinal we
still cherish the memory of his
words of appreciation and
encouragement
today we meet again and we  honors
of his presence he was president of
the european commission
perhaps the fronda line
cannot be forgotten that if this
event is possible it is due to the
efforts of the european union of
the italian authorities and to the sense of
responsibility of all citizens
in fighting and containing the pandemic
who impressed us
thanks illustrious president for what he has
done in his high responsibility and for
having accepted our invitation to
accompany us in this
exciting step for our
academic community with his
presence the ideal path begun with
last year's inaugural ceremony is completed
of which I mentioned earlier and
two elements are reunited  utives
of the identity of this
university its national dimension and the European one
in particular the latter is not an
accessory connotation but an
existential predicate of the university
in the first place because it is a university
and universities are in themselves bearers of
an intrinsically
European union itself would not have been
conceivable without that common matrix
of thought that universities have
helped to create and disseminate,
just as our universities
today are inconceivable if not within
the European system of higher education
and research
in  secondly this university is
even more profoundly European precisely
because it is Catholic I am not only alluding
to the decisive role of Christianity
in preserving the foundations of
Western culture
we are in a place that was a
Benedictine monastery and it is precisely here that twins speak
in 32 when it was inaugurated in
this  classroom said to us by those
unfamiliar with history can be observed
what a tradition we don't have and that
we are newcomers in the academic world
because we were born in 1921 but our
millenary tradition is the same
tradition that built these
magnificent cloisters bramante ski
a contribution to elaboration but
not a simple custody
decisive for the building of  a
spirit of the
continent brought it to light rémi brague in
his most famous work, however, the
wine and
underlining the ability
of Roman culture to place itself in a position of
cultural secondaryness by absorbing and
regenerating both
Greek and Judeo-Christian culture and making and
telling him  the very form of the
European relationship with cultural identity
that cultural permeability that
characterizes the common history of the
European peoples does not mean yielding or
weakness but the ability to
relate Europe emerges in the prolonged attempt
to see itself through the eyes
of the other
if one of the issues  crucial of
the globalized world and the capable  dialogue
this rests on an
inescapable premise clear self-knowledge
our university has been
constantly solicited almost challenged
to reflect on itself on fidelity
to the cultural project that gave it
origins and reason at the time of its
foundation the question was radical if
a  university that qualified as
catholic had space in a
scientific cultural ideological context that
seemed to deny it the answer lay
in the mandate that was attributed to the university
with lapidary synthesis by who would later
become pope science for
science ordered to life or
rather he explained by interpreting that admonition father
gemini  science sought without
any concern
without any prejudice loved science
is served as such and at
the same time attention to human beings scientific research
in order not to lose its way must
be ordered towards life or rather towards the good
of souls towards progress towards civilization
towards the greatness of
joint nations all  scientific research
education the university professor
must be ahead of everything he always says
twins an educator a trainer of
consciences an inspirer of souls and for
this reason the statute of his university
said perhaps only among the various statutes
of the universities he
places among the aims of the university
ours that it must not only educate the
young but also the ducals
it is an inspiration that is still
vital as demonstrated by the global
compact nor ducation which
passionately promoted by the holy father
stimulates with new freshness the
original ancient roots of this university
in the awareness that  education is
one of the keys to dealing with the
urgencies of the contemporary age
many people have responded to the Catholic's educational proposal, starting with the
first
courageous students whom I never tire of
counting among the founders of this
university and then by the increasingly numerous
young people who  they trusted
and allowed the university to contribute
to the development of the country with its more than
300,000 graduates,
many of them have already assumed
the highest level responsibilities
in the constituent assembly and later
in political,
institutional, economic and cultural roles and
with great importance in the
European institutions but it is even more significant  It is
worth mentioning
the contribution of knowledge that all
our graduates,
regardless of the positions
reached and the professions exercised, are
widespread in society
as operators and witnesses of a
culture and a well-defined moral and inspiration
from their
daily work.  the
reputation feeds the pride
of the university if the question of the origins
concerned the very legitimacy of a
Catholic university later in the
years the question
arose of the relevance of that
cultural project in a secularized world
crossed by movements of
youth protest  and in a church
called by the council it has a profound
renewal
according to some the threat was that of
regressing to an intellectual ghetto and
again the answer was given by
fearlessly participating in the
social debate to reaffirm, updating its
declination where necessary the values
of the Catholic university first the
seriousness of  educational action
and commitment to personal development
and
today we feel provoked by the new
questions posed by an era of uncertainty
the last few decades have in a certain
way been dominated by the topos of
complexity and guy morin who recently
turned 100 also  he explained it to us well
the complexity
questions the deductive logic that is
exercised on what is
parceled out and solicits the complexity
a return to the etymological root
of the intelligence of understanding
through a method of thought whose
essence is to connect and reconstruct the
connections  between the elements the context
the one and the multiple  the local and
global
or better according to his terminology the
planetarium but at least in the
widespread perception in the vulgarization that
of complexity and precisely and for a long time
appeared as a challenge that it was possible to take
up that it was possible to face
simply by refining the
known tools in short, confronting the
difficulties with the  light to overcome them
now the landscape seems shrouded in a
thicker epistemic fog that generates
awareness of the limits of that
ability to read reality in
natural reality as well as in social
and economic reality which in the season of
triumphant technological progress had
fueled a confident optimism about
the experience  confronts a
disturbing structural disorder a
real-world problem is never
separated with absolute certainty from
other things in that world
says douglas of death and there is no way to
predict what and how many other things
might be involved next
by effect d  i some small
variations compared to what is expected
phenomena such as climate change
the pandemic but the same could be
said of the sudden economic and
geopolitical crises that have shaken the
stability of the world we
face as problems whose solution
is not simply a question  of time
while in the era of the mastery of technology it
seemed that we were only
required to wait because in the end
every question would have been
answered and every goal from the
conquest of the moon to the defeat of
diseases would have been infallibly
achieved an
ineffable and elusive cognitive context like
today's  almost inevitably
also causes a loosening of the ties that
hold together the societies
shaken by unexpected threats the communities
do not gather around
unifying objective principles but are disbanded and
fragmented
ultimately an identity problem arises
which, as has been said, implies
a stable circle  le of recognitions
in duration a similar with in a similar
context the university must rediscover
its unifying role to position
itself as a community of many who
converge towards
1 a place once a spirit as
the holy father has just told us
to face the commitment of  universities
must not first of all conceive of themselves
as institutions it may even seem
idle to reiterate it but only the safety
and reliability of institutions can
reduce the degree of insecurity and
unpredictability that pervades our
democracies united europe itself has shown the
ability to give stimulus and hope
in  crisis generated by the pandemic
when it reaffirmed a
fundamental value of solidarity
understood not as an episodic relief action
but as recognition of the
common nature of a threat and
therefore of the need to
face them in a unitary perspective
side by
side  universities can then apply
to be one of the  points of welding between
knowledge development and public purposes by
operating directly, i.e. by
producing new knowledge
rescued from the privatization of
knowledge and its applications which they
confirm as growing as they are
disturbing both for me and
indirectly, i.e. through
training processes which contribute to creating
a  more cultured society and not only more
trained by spreading knowledge
as a social and political value there is
nothing new in this on the contrary it is
required to recover against the drifts
towards specialism at times it seemed
inevitable the fundamental dimension
of place of cultivation of an
integral knowledge  and therefore of an aspiration
to wisdom and knowledge and does not
have knowledge, i.e. knowledge
oriented and brought to life by the sense of
knowledge and again by armo rennes to
delimit the field of action when it poses
the problem of getting out of that
anthropological condition
that sees us still immature and
unprepared d  he face of what he
extraordinarily
powerfully calls the planetary iron age
well december this task
requires a reform of our way
of knowing a reform of our way
of thinking a reform of teaching
three interdependent reforms
on the basis of  these considerations
I think that a university like ours
should aim to operate as
a creative institution in a station
of disorientation and universities
appear to be among the few realities whose
function has remained almost intact and
pedagogically necessary for the growth
of generations is not a claim
but  assumption of responsibility to
maintain that role it is necessary to return
to the ancient mission of
the universitas that which john henry newman had already assigned to it,
namely that of giving shape to
an educated intellect, however compared to
newman's times the frame of reference
is no longer coherent the same idea  of
progress is no longer unequivocal
today it is necessary  dealing with creativity and
renewed ability to synthesize the themes
of the environment of health of the
dialectic with a technology that appears
elusive above and the need
for its rediscovered humanization the
old tools do not seem to be enough
a new look is needed a new
humanism the saint often tells us  father
and many voices of secular thought also tell us
now allow me to give a brief
account of some of the activities carried out
in the last year in the heart of our
university has kept the fire burning of
its training and study activity
I indicate some data without going into length
we have entrusted the  summary has a
mission statement that embraces the 100
years of experience of the
Catholic university and that an original document in its conception will be made
available to those present
which I hope
you will find interesting there
are 12 of our faculties have activated 104
degree courses and enrolled  training programs
including post-graduate programs
there are over 44,000 we are the first
Italian university according to the
international ranking for the presence of companies
on our campuses we are constantly at the
top in employers reputation
in six years international students
have grown by 59 percent and the
double degrees activated are now 24
in the past year  we have raised
funding and research for over 33
million euros and supported research
with our own funds for over 4 years.
Lastly, the commitment to support
the Catholic university students is intense and we
burn a total of 25 million euros
every year for the benefit of almost 10,000
students  making up for the
insufficiency of public resources, I
wo
n't add anything else having entrusted the
report to the documents we
talked about all this and much more,
as I mentioned, using
university resources the sources of these resources
deserve a mention to represent
an important evolution  that the catholic university has been there
over the years
ica was born handwriting
generous benefactors and was in the
beginning supported above all by the
offers of Italian Catholics a
choral participation you need a
university they felt they were part of the
church at the end of the sixties the
resources raised by the day for
catholic honesty thought developed by
indefatigable determination  of
armida barelli an amount equal
to half of the cost
of teachers' salaries reached them
the public contribution with the first the
remaining half
today the university is supported by
student contributions the other sources are
marginal it is an important fact because it
means that the university lives  thanks
to its ability to develop
an educational offer and to offer
services that deserve an investment
by students and their
families,
this has a double meaning, it
constitutes a decisive factor in the
freedom of the university which has
conquered an ever-difficult autonomy from the
point of view  economically  and has
conquered it thanks to the quality
of the offer it proposes and also certifies
that this university
belongs in the fullest sense to those
who teach and work in it and to the
students who attend it.
It seems to me that the
medieval meaning of the
universitas has been recovered in its sense  more
authentic
Catholic unity
with these characteristics
goes ahead and grows even in
difficult moments with prudent realism but without
being intimidated
during the year 2020 21 we have made
courageous investments and
we have planned others
two new campuses have been opened the one in brescia in
headquarters in mompiano and that of cremona in the
cloister of the monastery of santa monica
inaugurated last May
in the presence of the president of the
republic
important investments are planned
at the headquarters in rome to develop
the reception of students in
university colleges and to equip institutes
research and care of more and
more f  functional spaces and tools
but this belongs in a certain way
to the ordinary despite the intensity of
those commitments on this solemn
occasion I
am proud to be able to refer to an
important step for the definition of
what the face of the university will be in the
next century in the past  weeks
the
delivery report of the la santa valeria of
the garibaldi barracks in piazza
sant'ambrogio was signed and the agreement was finalized
with the municipality of milan and
the state property agency and the prefecture
which will allow the start of the
renovation works in the  I have spoken every time in the now 10
reports at the beginning of the year that I have
delivered in this classroom by them
announcing progress other times
confessing disappointment
now finally finally after years
of intense efforts an
aspiration that was already one of our
founders is fulfilled and we begin to
see concrete all  horizon the
possibility of creating a large
urban campus in the building that was
first a Franciscan convent and then a
military barracks to finally house the
state police,
a renewed place of study and culture will thus be returned to the city. I
sincerely thank all
those who have worked on this
project and the
numerous institutions which have been  at
our side to make
this project possible the
university is not a physical space it is a
man we understood it by contemplating the
painful void in the months of closures
and we understood it again when
we saw the young people eager to
return to their existential reality as
female students and the students  which is
conceivable only where the
universitas meets and becomes a community
the screens are projecting the
images of co they have projected the
images of what will become our new home together
with these historic and irreplaceable
cloisters
allow me to express while
aware that it will take time  and
efforts to see it defined
fully fulfilled the great emotion of thinking
that all this which for a long time has been an
almost skilful dream will become
reality there will be over 10 thousand
square meters 40 new classrooms and 1800 for for 4
thousand students only those that
will find space in the la that will
initially be delivered four  times
so when the work will have been
completed
I don't think a more significant gesture can be imagined
to mark the beginning
of the new century I
return in conclusion to the meaning
of the celebration of the centenary
in an article published a few months
ago it was observed that in a
society  wants secular and secularized there
is an increasingly
compulsive obsessive hunt for anniversaries to
be transformed not into celebrations but into
rituals we do not need to
invent new rituals but we
this anniversary has a
symbol value in the etymological sense the symbol
is known it was a means  of recognition
created by waiting for an object so that
the bearers  of each of the two
irregular fragments by making them fit together
they could recognize each other and identify themselves
this moment of transition that we are
experiencing therefore it joins it does not separate it makes
the before and after coincide by overcoming
but not abandoning in the sense of o
facebook and liana a past in which
our future is reflected
however  at the centenary it also evokes a strong
appeal one of the oldest
subdivisions of the time the
Jewish jubilee which was a moment of pause the
rest of the earth and of
even drastic redefinition of social and economic relations it
was a cycle which was completed by
a rebirth the milestones
of history  they always invite us to
look up from our
daily tasks and reflect on the goals of
our actions
thinking about a break a restart
these days is immediate and almost
inevitable
many activities have been suspended
slowed down some even zeroed
many have lost a lot of affection
economic security and in  many  the
psychological cases we have all lost as
before I was saying certainty now is the time to
return to fully responding to the
request for knowledge from our
students your madam president who
many have come here today to
attend this ceremony and to listen to you and I
thank you for agreeing to
meet them in the hall twins at the end
of this ceremony they are our part
of the next generation for them we are here
they represent regenerating the
initial motivation they
renew the founding act every year the
first stone laid a hundred years ago
when a professor enters the hall he
realizes  that in those different faces
every year but animated by the same expectation
of knowledge the sense
of the university institution is recreated the root
of its existence
looking at a crowded classroom and the
curious eyes of the students at the beginning of the
first lesson of the course one grasps the
value  prophetic
of martin heidegger's expression
the beginning is still not at our
spa  lle as an event long past
but it stands before us
[Applause] I
invite His Excellency Archbishop
Monsignor del Pini, President
of the Toniolo Institute of Higher Studies,
to address his greetings, thank you,
there is a mission from the university
catholic there is not only a service to be
rendered to the students there is a mission
that concerns this time this land
this europe it seems to me that in europe I am
gathering signs of
sadness
perhaps
symptoms of a fatal disease
perhaps challenges for a new civilization
the signs of  sadness if I can
decipher them sincerely they can be
gathered from some areas
of academic activity too
there is a principle of sadness
in the unhappiness of mortified critical thinking
and to be a grammar
of suspicion
there is a principle of sadness in
the reduced legal culture
he competence of the procedures
there is a principle of sadness in the
paths of economics and finance
that end in the formation of
functionaries
organic to the system
the catholic university has a mission
in fact critical thinking can
be happy if it is discernment
to introduce amazement legal culture
can offer
motivation to the
enterprise of fixing the world if it
introduces the art of politics and
civil coexistence
according to justice
, economic competence
can be
qualified to be responsible for
the integral economy,
in short, the culture developed in a
Catholic university has the mission of
testifying and
configuring a humanism of hope,
it does not like the aggressive tones of
ideology, it does not like the bitter words of
discouragement,
it does not like  naive enthusiasms of a
technology that exonerates from the
responsibility of thinking about deciding on
alternative paths
the catholic university offers its
contribution to the culture of this time
with the pride and modesty of someone who has
a mission to accomplish and has faith
in the works of men and  of the women
who in these op  ere there is a light a
promise even a gladness
reflection of the glory of god
the remedy for sadness i believe is not
the voluntarism of resistance it is not
the greed of conquest it is not the ardor
of competition
but a humanism of hope
this is mine  wish is my
prayer for all the components
of the catholic university of the sacred
heart for which we inaugurate the academic year
[Applause]
now please, president, the lady
president of the European commission to
carry out her collusion
[Applause]
magnificent rector
excellency ashby shop of the pd
minister gelmini
del monti
members of
honor
patrizia toia
president prodi
mail
distinguishes estoril test
ansa croci
catholic university catholic
academy
generations of italy
generation
institution
for generation of leaders
[Music]
romano prodi as
professor
thank you
new generation
and belongs to the next  generation
catholic university
on solid professor
thank you
t  hank you for
the
next generation
games
director of slayers
news
innovation
and democracy
generation
milan
energy consumption
off-site students
compass
[Applause]
in
estate
inclusive
nel
milan
in
fact
innovation project
with porto di mare
and
lance harris poll by sky
news
new york
[Music]
university
bosco
[Music]
education
education and europe
[Music]
the
magnificent rector
philosophers science
university
of
change
and shapes and
just like
university
di angel of change because the great
place to work
all
catholic university
[Music]
unique edition
ultimate
force
dow
jones
box
and
change
democracy  and
stands
out
online
game over
songs pick up
flights to europe for  young people and I want
a Europe
of young people
[Applause]
francis
[Music]
e visa
europe
e
[Music]
catholic university merry christmas long live
europe
[Applause]
thank you
the president for your speech
which we needed
equipped with  sace spaceman I
thank all those present who have honored us with
their participation the
authorities
colleagues the students
and I declare the academic year
2021 2022 of the uni svagato ricadesse open
[Music]
no
[Applause]
[Music]
[  Applause]
[Applause]